Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they just
announced a bunch more versions of Spider-Man
that are going to be in Spider-Man Across the
Spider-Verse and there are some big ones there's
at least six new major ones so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos it has been
a minute since I've done a Spider-Man across the
spider-verse video but the movie is coming out
June 2023 so once we start getting more footage
and previews I will do more videos for the movie
but probably the first biggest new version is Tom
Holland's MCU Spider-Man from the 616 Universe
there's been so much talk about him being in a
version of Spider-Man into the spider-verse
there was actually a deleted scene where he
was supposed to be in that first movie at one
point I was supposed to be in it yeah there was
going to be another Peter Parker like it was like
a scene in a train station or something and like
it was it was going to be like a
like an Easter egg I was going to
walk through the background and say like
Hey kid or something and never happened
um but I'm just excited for us to introduce
miles into our own Universe one day I think
that's going to be really cool should be wild as
far as I know is cameo in the sequel is supposed
to be an animated Cameo because the whole deal
in the sequel is that Miles Morales is traveling
across the spider versus like he's traveling
across different universes instead of everybody
coming to his Universe I guess it is possible
that it could be a live-action Cameo because
they did talk about doing live action cameos in
the first movie but they thought it was just like
a little two meta there was a little bit of live
action with the popsicle but like that was about
it because this is taking place after the events
of Spider-Man no way home I assume he's going to
be wearing his brand new Spider-Man suit that
he got at the end of that movie though if you
remember the very early trailers from Spider-Man
into the spider-verse a couple years ago you may
have spotted his Cameo scene so he's in the early
trailers or at least his scene was in the early
trailers but I think they wound up deleting his
scene because of scheduling problems because when
they were working on that movie when they would
have been working on his Cameo scene he was still
busy working on Avengers Infinity War Avengers
endgame and Spider-Man far from home so I think
it was mostly a timing issue at the time and
they just had trouble working out a deal for him
because it's still Sony making that Spider-Man
into the spider-verse Spider-Man across the
spider-verse movies so they have much more say
in what Tom Holland does but they still have to
work out a special deal for him to do that stuff
when I said it's in those original trailers this
is the scene that he's talking about where they
talk about the other versions of Spider-Man it's
really quick blinking you'll miss it but if you
remember it was in those original teaser trailers
wait so how many of us are there
the next two biggest ones are both Toby
Maguire Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man versions there's been talk
about bringing them back for a long time Phil
Lord Chris Miller the producers of all the
spider-verse movies said that they talked to
the Sony Executives about doing Cameo scenes with
them when they were pitching the very first film
many years ago but because we're talking about
like 2015 2016 2017 the Sony Executives at the
time said that it was too soon so just everybody
laugh about that too soon we literally just got
done watching Spider-Man no way home where all
the live-action versions cameo'd together like
they did a live action spider-verse on a low level
you like make your own web fluid in your body I'd
rather not talk about it you've never had a web
block because I run out of webs all the time I
have to make my own in a lab but I I did actually
you said that I was like oh I had a web block why
existential crisis stuff so cool man like I
want to see the holes hey unbelievable what
was Sony thinking too soon to do a cameo scene
back in 2018 you also have to remember that at
that time when they were pitching the movie this
was like 2016-2017 that they didn't know that
Andrew Garfield or Toby Maguire would be coming
back for Spider-Man no way home for the third
Spider-Man live-action movie that didn't really
become a thing until right before they actually
started making the film like what if we actually
got them to come back and then it turned into a
big deal and happened pretty quickly but that was
until like 2019 when they started working on that
my assumption is that the Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield Cameo scenes would be separate scenes and
just like the Tom Holland MCU Spider-Man scene
it would be miles traveling across everyone's
universes and that's how they'd Cameo them since
I posted my last trailer they also confirmed
that spider Punk is going to be another big
character they've also said that Yuri Lowenthal
is supposed to have a cameo scene as a version of
Spider-Man PS4 from the video game like literally
the PlayStation game version of Spider-Man
will have a cameo like I said I'm assuming
miles traveling through the universe of the game
that totally feels like something in the tone
of the spider-verse movies like them just doing
really meta stuff like yeah we're gonna have some
live-action Cameo scenes but they'll be animated
probably and we'll have some video game Cameo
scenes like all kinds of universes everything is
connected through the spider-verse talking about
some more nostalgic deep cuts too older versions
of Spider-Man there's been more talk of them doing
a version from Spider-Man the Animated Series in
the 90s his voice actor was Christopher Daniel
Barnes who himself talked about being in the
sequels back when the first movie came out it's
still one of the best animated series that Marvel
has ever done and my favorite animated Spider-Man
series if you want early teasers for Madame Webb
or Secret Wars they did both on that series the
version of Secret Wars that they did though was
the 1980s version with the beyonder not the more
recent version which I think is going to inspire
more of the plot during Avengers 6. like the more
modern version of Secret Wars but we talk about
Spider-Man across the spider-verse getting super
meta with all these different easter eggs they
just had that big scene on She-Hulk where she
had a cameo scene with a real life version of
Kevin Feige played by robot when are we getting
the X-Men I cannot tell you that Spider-Man the
Animated Series did something like this almost 30
years ago so you could say that She-Hulk is
kind of ripping off Spider-Man the Animated
Series if you didn't watch that series at the end
Spider-Man travels to the Marvel Comics offices
in a universe and has a meeting with a real live
version of Stan Lee who did The Cameo himself like
it was a great Stanley Cameo scene and Spider-Man
learns that he's a fictional character that Stan
Lee created to sell comics and they legit just
have a heart to heart with each other the even
more meta thing is that in this scene Madame Webb
makes the Multiverse Cameo possible like takes him
into this universe to meet Stan Lee and she was
actually voiced on the series by Stan Lee's wife
in real life named Joan he even literally makes
a reference to that during the actual Cameo scene
like you sound very familiar I'm looking for some
guy named Stan Lee what what Spiderman Spiderman
it's time to go who is that exotic lady wow I
wonder how I'm supposed to get down from here
I suppose I could wait for the Fantastic Four to
drop by and give me a lift personally I think that
that meta Cameo scene is a little bit better than
the She-Hulk Kevin feige Cameo scene but that's
just my personal opinion there's also talk of them
doing a cameo scene with Josh Keaton's Spectacular
Spider-Man even though that series isn't quite
as precious to me a lot of younger adults now
watched it as little kids and still think of it as
their favorite animated Spider-Man series probably
one of the biggest things that's also happened
since we started getting Spider-Man across the
spider-verse trailers is that hailee Steinfeld
Who plays Spider Gwen during these movies has
also started playing the live-action version
of Kate Bishop Hawkeye inside the MCU so talk
about meta crossover I'm sure at some point
there'll be some jokes about that especially
when they start doing the Press tour for
the movie no no come on that is so annoying
there was talk about her potentially playing a
live-action version of spider-gwit at one point
I don't know that's gonna happen now just because
she is playing Kate Bishop so it becomes a little
bit crazier but if we're talking about Multiverse
heading to Secret Wars I suppose there's room for
literally anything like nothing should be off the
table technically and quick reminder Spider-Man
across the spider-verse is a two-part movie that's
right they're doing the Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game thing where they split the movie
into two different parts we're getting part one
next year in part two the year after that so there
won't be a giant wait for part two of the movie
one of the key differences between this movie
and the first Spider-Man into the spider-verse
movie is the first movie was all about other
characters coming to Miles Morales Universe
the Ultimate Spider-Man universe the sequels
is going to be the opposite it'll be him going
to other universes inside the spider-verse but
if it wasn't clear from that when they traveled
to other universes they use different animation
styles for each different version of Spider-Man's
universe so for example in the trailer there's
a lot of footage of Miles Morales traveling to
this alternate universe of Spider-Man India's
universe he's a Hindu Spider-Man so everything's
drawn in an Indian themed animation style for
that country the same is true when he goes to
Spider-Man 2099's universe in Nueva York in
the future also explained that too like how
can he travel in time when he's traveling between
universes if you spotted in any other new ones
that I didn't mention in the video that you've
heard them tease or talk about just write them
Below in the comments my black panther wakanda
forever movie review will post on Tuesday after
they let us in my full post credit scene video
break down Easter eggs for the entire movie we'll
post later in the week after it actually comes out
so be sure to go see the movie as soon as possible
this week everyone click here for my Ant-Man
3 Quantumania trailer with a whole bunch of
easter eggs a whole bunch of Kang the conqueror
and click here for my full Spider-Man across the
spider-verse trailer from a little while ago
and the many many versions that they already
announced thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!